let's go as I often like to do to a
possible local caller from the six one
seven area code six one seven caller
who's this oh hi David can you hear me
we can hear you who's this hi it's Terry
I've called in the show a few times
before I'm just actually at this time
I'm calling from Washington DC at
American University okay I go to school
here
I stand corrected go ahead Terry um last
week or I think it was the week before
Dave Reuben came out with this video
about socialism yeah and I was kind of
taken aback in part because of some odd
reference to Martin Luther King that
David that Dave did which I didn't feel
like made a lot of sense but also
because I felt like a lot of the talking
points like David like really like God
can like really tried like bumbled up
together and didn't really make it
coherent argument of why socialism was
bad and I also didn't like how this
became like a huge issue because you
know about the YouTube account ad
pocalypse apparently the video the
original video that Dave's put up got
demonetised so he then did another one
called capitalism is it cool to test to
see if YouTube has arm has basically an
anti capitalist or socialist binary
because I feel like the discussion is it
week there's really lights like very
difficult to critique the capitalism at
Leon's video because the fact of that
YouTube ad pocalypse but are getting
back on track I was just wondering like
do you think there's a good way to like
make like offer like a rebuttal today
Dave because I could you know I know you
said you liked on Richard Wolffe and I
figured you know maybe if Dave has on
like Richard Wolffe that might be a good
way to basically uh learn Dave to learn
kind of like kind of some parts of why
his some of his arguments against
socialism aren't good I was just
wondering what you had to say so listen
first of all for people in the audience
who don't know what video Terry's
talking about Dave Rubin a host of the
Rubin report did a video last week or
the week before it was around Martin
Luther King Day I think right called
socialism isn't cool
and it was I mean socialism isn't cool
isn't really an argument but it was a
video that received a bunch of attention
now if you are if your question is
should dave rubin interview rich marxist
economist richard wolf if he exposed to
other ideas I would say sure I don't
know if that's an interview that Dave
Rubin is interested in doing I don't
know what interviews at this point he is
and isn't interested in doing that was
supposed to be the idea behind his show
right bring on people from all different
sides of the political spectrum and of
course increasingly it's been sort of
right-wing or as dave says it's because
left wingers won't go on but I've
offered to go on cedar cedar has offered
to go on maybe we're not the right sort
of left wingers I mean Terry I think the
problem is that a lot of times there's
this desire for these black/white
arguments like capitalism is good
socialism is bad and most clear-thinking
people increasingly understand that in a
planet of seven billion people that has
had you know drastically different
circumstances over the time that modern
humans have been on the planet two
hundred and fifty thousand years that
really it's very hard to make any
definitive black-and-white statement
that that holds true a hundred percent
of the time so like for example I think
that there are capitalistic elements
that are really good for certain areas
of society but I think that we need
regulation I think that we need to
ensure that we are properly funding
social welfare programs and the Commons
and so my economic views increasingly
align more and more with like the
Scandinavian model which is well
regulated capitalism with strong Commons
so does that mean I think capitalism is
or isn't cool does it mean I think
socialism is or isn't cool I don't know
but those aren't really arguments and
it's not the way that you're really
going to achieve or learn to to much
that would be my response you know thank
you thanks David all right well thank
you thank you for calling it I guess I
must have said it all in that that
answer I think Dave Rubin would think
that it was a catchy title for the video
draw people in and that also there's
this crop of younger kids who think that
because they've seen a Bernie Sanders
rally and maybe you read his book that
socialism is cool now and although again
probably what he was trying to
yeuch he's not talking about socialism
he's talking about a version of
capitalism that is regulated right a
social democracy and then there's also a
democratic socialism